physical gold is the only independent
scarce
and enduring
financial assets it's the only financial
asset that is tangible
and it's the only tangible asset that is
financial asset i'm simon mikhailovich
i'm the managing partner of the boolean
reserve
which is a vehicle for managing private
bullion reserves of institutional and
high net worth investors
outside the financial system
the purpose of gold basically it's an
independent liquidity reserve
it is something that can be uh
negotiated in exchange for
either currency or goods or barter the
misconception is that it's something
obsolete and irrelevant cash flow is not
the only measure of intrinsic value when
liquidity dries up
independent liquidity
has the highest value at that point
because a it enables somebody to meet
their obligations where other people
cannot meet their obligations and thus
survive through the trough of the crisis
and b it enables such individuals to
potentially deploy this liquidity and
invest it in deeply depreciated assets
that are depreciated precisely because
other people do not have liquidity and
are now forced to sell
in order to raise
money
so if you for example step away and say
well
what happens when cash flows stop coming
what happens when the valuation
methodologies that are applied to value
in cash flows
are suddenly applied to all of financial
assets
that's called correlation goes to one
which means everything the price of
everything goes down
what happened to subprime mortgages
subprime mortgages were valued based on
present value of future cash flows there
was an assumption as to the future cash
flows and when that is one assumption
proved to have been incorrect the entire
complex collapsed
so having an asset
that is not reliant on those assumptions
but on some other measures of value
is a primary source of diversification
in these circumstances what we're
worried about is a disruption within the
realm of
realistic possibilities and
the important thing with gold in this
sense is electronic disruption
can cause permanent damage to digital
assets because not only the uh trading
and the
relationships are all conducted
digitally but the assets the shares uh
the bonds they're digital as well
they're digital records gold inherently
itself is not digital so you may have
interrupted excess for a short period of
time but the asset itself does not get
impaired so for that meaning for the
complete disruption
people should have
some gold on hand that would be in the
forms let's say of coins
or small bars just for that level of
emergency
[Music]
you